all right so it's a pleasure to welcome
you today to this wonderful conversation
about happiness and or the life
well-lived i'm kim graf cruz secretary
and vice president for student life this
event is sponsored by the yale well
initiative and that initiative brings
together resources from across the
university to support students in
embracing personal wellness including
emotional physical social intellectual
professional and spiritual well-being so
check out the Yale well website for more
events and programs like this one we
have today three wonderful speakers who
are going to reflect on happiness and
its relationship to a life well-lived
where else of course can we learn about
these topics than from our own Yale
faculty we are going to start with each
of our speakers this afternoon making
remarks for about 25 minutes including
questions from you and when we get to
that portion we're going to ask that you
raise your hand we'll have two roving
mics and they will come someone will
come to you our first speaker will be
Laurie Santos she is a professor of
psychology in head of silliman college
professor Santos research focuses on the
question of what makes the human mind
unique she answers by comparing humans
cognition to that of dogs and primates
but she has also been in the news
recently as we all know because of her
Yale College course unhappiness the
largest course that's ever been taught
at Yale she tried out some of the
material in a wellness project at
Sunland College which was partially
funded by the Yale well initiative if
you aren't one of her current students a
version of the course now called the
science of well-being is now available
on Coursera so check it out our second
speaker will be Jennifer hurt
Russell heard is the Gilberts lstart
professor and associate dean of academic
affairs at the Divinity School and she
holds a secretary appointment in the
Department of Religious Studies she is
perhaps best known for her work on
virtues what type of character do we
need to lead a good life but she also
thinks about ethical form a
or building I think is what in German
and has recently finished a book on this
topic our third speaker will be shelly
kagan professor Kagan is the Clark
professor of philosophy he has worked on
questions about well-being and what it
means to deserve something and is known
for thinking about how ethics relates to
rules and consequences he has a course
online too but this one is about death a
topic that we cannot avoid however much
we might want to the course has been
extremely popular in China and Korea and
it's just another example of the global
reach of all of our faculty so I along
with you I know we're looking forward to
hearing three views on what makes for a
happy life and how happiness is related
to a good life so please join me in
welcoming our first speaker Laurie
Santos thanks so much I'm gonna I'm
gonna sit here I'm channeling Shelley
who I know well maybe you want to sit
later so I'm just gonna do that but
thanks so much took him for inviting me
here to speak about this topic I thought
what I would do today is to tell you all
a little bit about the story of this
course that I'm teaching I'm asked to
speak about this course a lot these days
and so I thought it would be fun to sort
of think about what the social sciences
might say about happiness and the good
life kind of through the lens of this
course and why I wanted to teach it in
the first place so as Kim mentioned I'm
a professor of psychology I do work with
non-human animals but I'm broadly
interested in questions related to
decision making how we make decisions
how we allow situations to shape
ourselves and sort of how we can use
like the science of psychology to
initiate behavioural change actually did
work on this with non-human primates
trying to look at what kinds of biases
are built into our decision-making and
can we use situations to overcome those
and it was that kind of work wasn't the
kind of work that actually launched my
interest in starting this psychology and
the good life class that class oddly
even though it is a psychology class
came out of my other hat Yale which is
being a professor and a head of college
so I'm head of silliman College and I
think most of you know what that means
but if you're in the professional
schools and are less familiar with
Yale's residential colleges
these are kind of like the hogwarts
version of smaller residential
communities where students live with
faculty with their head of college and
their dean and as a head of college you
really get to see what student life is
like up close and personal and that was
when i started to realize that the the
undergrads weren't really as happy as we
sometimes think or kind of as
flourishing as we sometimes think i was
just recently googling during google
image searches for my class and i google
image you know college students and if
you do that you get a whole set of
images of like happy students happy
students working or happy students
studying in a courtyard happy happy
happy but like if you look at the data
what you see is that that just doesn't
seem to be what's going on in college
these days like the data are pretty
striking so a recent national college
health survey is not actually that
recent right now is from 2009 was the
last one that we have available suggest
that like lots and lots of students are
more unhappy than we think so over
eighty percent report being so
overwhelmed all the time they don't have
time to do the things that they want to
do around 50 percent report being
anxious in the 30 percent range of
students who report being so depressed
it's difficult to function around 50
percent report being very lonely and
most of them report having at least an
above-average level of stress around 10
percent report having the maximum
possible stress that they could imagine
right and this was now almost a decade
ago and my guess is that those
statistics have gotten worse over time
and this was the kind of thing i was
seeing in the trenches in silliman which
is that obviously students are
incredibly privileged to be here at a
place like Yale but there's this
question of it what cost like what I
found is that students weren't really
paying attention to kind of the things
that were important in life they were
prioritizing things like grade kind of
worries about their future salary and so
on but what I watched was them missing
out on their time here at Yale and so I
thought really carefully about what to
do about this and because I'm a social
scientist and that's my expertise I
thought carefully about okay what does
the science of psychology say about how
to deal with this stuff like what does
it really say about what we should be
doing to increase our happiness and not
just what we should be doing to increase
our happiness but like how can we make
those good goals stick because if
there's one thing we know but the
science of human nature it's that we can
have lots of very positive goals we
often stick to them that's why even
though we're now in April right we're
not even a third of the way through the
year most year New Year's resolutions
are like completely out the door to the
point right like you could have good
goals things you want to achieve but
it's really hard to make them stick and
so I thought what if we designed a class
that talked about all this research the
research about the kinds of things that
make us happy and what we can do to put
those things into effect and as Kim
mentioned we we tried this course out in
a smaller kind of seminar version at
silliman college through a gracious
grant that her office was kind enough to
give us at silliman and the few students
who went to that course really reported
getting something out of it so we
thought well I'll scale this up and turn
this into real you know college class
and what I didn't expect was the
response to this class first I'll tell
you a little bit about what the class is
trying to do what what the students
talked about and then I'll talk a little
bit about the response because I think
that's important and so the class as I
mentioned is this combination of the
science of what what you can do to
achieve the good life and what you can
do to sort of think about what will we
make you happy and in doing that it
starts with some misconceptions about
what makes us happy kinds of things that
we think make us happy but DOE and I
think this is one of the puzzles that we
get from social science is the fact that
our mind delivers to us these intuitions
about the kinds of things that will make
us happy but sometimes those intuitions
and data suggest are just wrong we
forecast that something will make us
happy we forecast having a fantastic
salary or awesome new house or for
undergraduate students having really
perfect grades we forecast those things
will make us happy but they don't make
us as happy as we think the flipside is
that there's all these things that
really will make us happy the kinds of
things that in the moment will make us
feel more flourish more fulfilled and so
on but we don't often have these
motivations to seek those things out and
so there's a disconnect between the
things we want and the things that are
gonna really have an effect and so the
class starts with that starts by
convincing so you know sometimes your
mind lies to you and we go through this
in gory detail showing students lots of
visual illusions like all these kids
really like yep I'm on board
sometimes my mind's not telling me what
I think and then we get to stuff like
having good grades your mind might be
lying to you there too and it's a little
harder for students to kind of realize
like oh wait it might be lying to me
there too and then we try to talk about
like what is it about human psychology
that means the mind might be lying to us
about what we want and then we kind of
go through things that you should seek
out these sort of healthier practices
and then we talk about what you can do
from the perspective of social science
to kind of if you want to choose to go
after those goals that really will make
you happy how can you get yourself to
stick to those and that's the sort of
period of the course that students are
in right now but I think one of the
things that makes the course unique is
that it's not just a course on the
social science side it's not just the
science of psychology I wanted the
course to be about the practice of
psychology too and that's for a really
good reason which is that another thing
social science teaches us is that merely
knowing this stuff knowing the stuff
we're supposed to do is just not enough
you actually have to allow your
situations to be there to help you gain
these habits to do a little bit better
and so the course in addition to having
its typical course requirements like a
midterm and quizzes and a final paper we
also in the syllabus have what I call
course requirements and they're kind of
like requirements but their requirements
that are meant to rewire your habits and
students every week have one of these I
think this week students requirements is
that they're supposed to use their
character strengths with another person
and seek out some social support for
doing that but these requirements
include things like having time set
aside for meditation taking time for
gratitude taking time to sleep which is
one that students I think found
particularly hard taking time to do
random acts of kindness we pulled these
requirements from the literature and
positive psychology on things that we
know are practices that can kind of bump
up happiness bump up happiness either in
a very momentary way or in a slightly
more long-term way but students are
assigned these tasks to do and the hope
is that it will cause them to kind of
think of them like a normal you know
problem set that's coming up it's like
in the syllabus they have to do this
this week and hopefully it will it's the
kind of thing that can help them achieve
these sorts of goals it's exactly the
kind of situational support the research
suggests will help so I designed this
whole class the course of study really
liked it I say this is great you know
it's new class maybe you know 50
students if I'm lucky like maybe 100
students will take this class and then
as professor isn't during shopping
period I don't really know how many
students are gonna take the class we're
kind of watching
enrollments for this class growing and
growing and growing in fact growing past
the largest class rooms on yells campus
and at its peak I think the class was
around twelve hundred and seventy
students which at the time was over one
out of four students at Yale which was
pretty incredible
it was incredible logistically because
we didn't really have a classroom that
could fit students
it was incredible in terms of the demand
because I think it really showed that
there was a need for this kind of
conversation on campus I think a
conversation that you know as the other
speakers my address should be broader
than just to social sciences like I mean
that was what my course was trying to do
but I think students would have come in
as many droves if it was a conversation
that maybe came out of philosophy or
maybe even out of faith-based
communities but it was clear that there
was a real need for this kind of course
on campus and so with the help of Dean
Chun whose office was amazing at this we
decided not to cap the class we somehow
managed to find 25 GS to TF the class
and we launched the class and it's kept
going and so you might ask like wow like
you know how's it going like you know
what have we seen so far and where it's
tricky to say because we're still kind
of a little bit in the middle of this
experiment we're kind of you know about
you know two-thirds maybe issue of the
way through the semester but I've seen a
few things so far that have really
surprised me one is that the students
really resonate with these requirements
and many of them report doing them very
religiously almost like you know the
problem sets in the syllabus they're
gonna do these requirements too and
students report that when they do these
things you know they are experiencing
all the things that the research might
suggest which is that they're feeling
more socially connected in some cases
feeling less lonely many of them have
done things like opted out of social
media delete their social media accounts
they report experiencing less social
comparison and less anxiety many of them
who've taken on the gratitude practices
are noticing things about this place
that they haven't noticed before
like how much they like their classes or
their friends things that might have
just been blind to them when they are
worried about internships and
fellowships and so on
and it's allowed me to see in some ways
how many students need these kinds of
practices like how like little self care
students were doing
generally so one of the things we did
for the class one of the practices we
talked about in classes what's called
time affluence which is just simply
having some extra times on free time
that is not scheduled just something
that's very rare for Yale students and
to teach Yale students about time
affluence I decided to do a little
tricky thing which is I had in the
syllabus a lecture on time athletes but
when students came to that lecture I
actually canceled class that day I said
your lecture on time affluence is now
you have time affluence here's an hour
and the rule was just that you can't you
know don't go study for a midterm like
don't just do what you would normally do
at that hour don't schedule it
immediately just have free time and do
something that would be a nice piece of
self care and upon telling students
about this I was there at Battelle
Chapel handing out these flyers
explaining time affluence to students
spontaneously burst into tears when I
told them this this was around midterm
time so students are very kind of
stressed a couple I think about seven or
eight students hugged me thank you thank
you so much but many of the students
wrote back to me and told me what they
did and they did things like take a walk
with friends to East Rock Park or go
with their suite mates the recording
studio and just jam or sit in the
courtyard and have a bubble tea it just
happened to be a nice sunny day when
students were there
this was like a one-hour break that
students like a simple one-hour that
students like reported like you know I'm
gonna remember this day this is gonna be
a day that I remember and undergrad for
the rest of my life like this was the
coolest thing ever it was like one hour
that they had free and so again we're
still kind of in the middle of this
experiment but basically what I'm
learning is I think that these simple
practices as kind of band ad as they are
on the big culture they seem like
they're already having a bigger
difference than even I expected and the
final thing I'll mention before I open
it up to questions is kind of the other
strange thing that I didn't expect about
this experiment and that's how much it's
struck a chord beyond yells campus as
many of you probably saw the course was
featured in a New York Times article
that article in some sense went viral
I've been on now I think six different
national news media stations the class
has been covered that it based on my
last count in about fourteen different
languages and in 14 different countries
I've had to solicit student
who speak different languages to help me
handle the press from other countries
that are coming in and one student who
from Colombia that I think has been on
like eight different shows he's like a
national celebrity and calm you know but
the the point of telling you that is
that what we're seeing is that like this
idea of kind of using social science to
think about what the good life means
seems to have struck a chord really
broadly and it seems like it's the kind
of thing that's not just needed at the
college level but maybe beyond like a
number of the emails I'm getting art
from other college professors about
wanting to kind of come up with a
similar course but are from high school
teachers and middle school teachers were
asking about developing this content
more broadly and so I think it the
course has been more popular than I
expected it's been more needed than I've
expected it's been more needed at more
different levels than I expected I think
we'll continue to learn a lot by the end
of the course I'm really looking forward
to the course evaluations and hearing
what students have to say in a more
formal way but I think it's showed that
we need more of these kinds of
conversations on campus and at least one
kind of prong of those conversations
will involve really thinking deeply
about what the social sciences have to
say about what it means a little good
life and with that I want to open up for
questions and make sure we have time for
that and I'm told I think I was supposed
to remind you to make sure you wait for
the microphone to ask
thank you I have two questions my first
is you mentioned that you think that
there was a really open response to this
because it wasn't tied to any religion
or philosophy but rather just to social
sciences which is very neutral and
non-judgmental however I'm curious if
during putting this course together and
seeing the the changes that your
students are making if you have come to
appreciate any particular habits or
practices from common religious
traditions more or conversely if you
have decided that certain habits or
practices from religious traditions are
kind of widespread and not helpful yeah
great question so just to clarify I
think what I meant to say maybe I could
have said it wrong is that I think this
this class came from the social sciences
but I think this class would have had as
much of an interest on campus if it came
from any of these different traditions I
think there was a philosopher Lassa fee
in the good life I think if there was a
kind of faith in the good life I think
it would have been just as much of it I
think no no as big because as big is
kind of weird like the you know biggest
in the history of Yale but I think I
think students really want this and they
it's not specific to the social sciences
I think the social sciences provide an
interesting angle and I think the social
science especially the social size of
behavioral change is kind of hot
anyway right now we here at the School
of Management which thinks a lot about
behavioral economics and that kind of
thing but just to be clear I think this
could have come from anywhere it just
happened that it was my class at this
time but on to the question about you
know how much how much of what I'm
teaching students comes from faith based
practices the the the thing that's
humbling for the social sciences is that
many of the things that I'm talking
about things like making social
connections or experiencing gratitude
doing random acts of kindness taking
time for meditation or mindfulness --is
I mean these just come straight out of a
faith-based playbook different religious
traditions have been talking about
related sorts of practices for a long
time and mostly what we're finding is
that those kinds of practices are borne
out in the social science data when you
really do the empirical work to try to
see if these practices are helping you
what you find is that in
by and large they tend to and you know
so it's humbling for the social sciences
to realize like oh you you could have
done you could have come at this from a
very different tradition and gotten the
same sort of answer in terms of specific
practices from religion that that don't
work super well you're trying to think
of any specific ones that have come up I
mean by and large what the research
suggests is one thing that it tends to
be the case in very happy people is that
if you look very happy people tend to be
on average more religious than people
who report not being very happy and I
think there's an open question about
what aspects of religion allow that to
be the case
some people have argued that it's the
more faith-based aspects it's about
belief systems is about believing and
meaningful things believing in the
afterlife and so on but in practice when
you look at the data it seems to be by
and large based on these specific
healthy practices particularly things
like community and social connection
when you factor those out you tend to
lose the correlation between religion
and happiness so so we're not totally
sure what the specific practices are I
haven't found any that I'm like that's a
practice that religion prescribes
totally does it not borne out in the
social science data but it would be neat
to look more but specifically
hi I was just wondering what is your
working definition of happiness because
it's always ups and downs so when these
students are kind of coming in what is
what are they supposed to be
benchmarking towards that sounds to
business.you but yeah no totally totally
what I'm I'm a social scientist I'm all
about goodness you know and so one thing
on that which is that when I design the
course the reason I called it psychology
in the good life that I didn't mention
happiness at all is that I wanted to
leave those definitions of happiness to
the other fields who in some ways do it
better than social science like the
reason I called it the good life is I
actually think that this is one of the
things that we miss want which is that
we think we want happiness by which I'll
define something like you know positive
emotion all the time and increasing
pleasure and kind of hedonism I think
that's what our mind seeks out we want
better and better stuff and bigger and
bigger salaries and more and more
positive experiences but actually what
really will cause that positive emotion
over time is the kinds of practices that
are our less focused on the hedonistic
stuff and more focused on things that
build meaning and create social
connection and allow you to have
meaningful collaborations with people
and so on so the point of that is just
to say I was trying to be really careful
I actually didn't mention happiness in
the course at all and if you look at the
syllabus we kind of downplay it we use
well-being and all these kind of like
other like terms for it but every time
the course is talked about it's like
it's the Happiness course no it's not
it's like kind of something different
but you ask how I define happiness in
the class I'm gonna use the social
scientist definition which kind of has
two parts one part is what social
scientists think of as a kind of
cognitive definition of well-being which
is sort of like your own beliefs and
evaluation of your own life which can be
summed up nicely by like I've asked you
how are things going like you know how's
your life satisfaction in general how
satisfied are you how happy are you you
have the answer for that this is kind of
like your meta evaluation of how things
are going the social scientists also try
to measure happiness in the moment by
which they mean your positive and
negative emotions and so I could ask you
you know how often you know today have
you experienced a positive emotion how
often you been feeling happy or feeling
grateful or all these I have a whole set
of cinema's a positive emotion versus
negative ones how often have you felt
guilty or sad or all these things and I
just add those up and come up with a
number and the idea is we want more
positive emotions and less negative
emotions that's how the social
scientists are defining it all the
studies that we nearly all the studies
that we talked about in class are using
a completely crude measure like that and
as a social scientist I realize that's
an incredibly crude measure for an
incredibly rich thing but those are the
kinds of things who are talking about
and that was one of the reasons I was
trying to be careful about my
definitions I didn't want to claim to be
measuring something I wasn't but I
didn't get away with it in fact high so
seems like there's a lot of value placed
and Happiness positive emotions what
role do you assign to other emotions to
the rest of the repertoire which are
also important to keep a balance and so
we don't shy away and sort of get
permission to ourselves to feel
nostalgic melancholic sad at times and
how these combination ends up being a
part of what would also lead to a
balanced happiness we can't just be you
know these high happiness at all times
yeah agreed
and I think that's kind of I guess I'll
mention two things that you get about
that from the social science so one is
that I think again our lay perspective
are kind of like deep automatic
motivations like left to their own
devices are gonna seek out the positive
emotion all the time right like that's
what you think you're trying to maximize
for all the things we seek out and
oftentimes but what you find is that
like actually probably what's gonna like
allow you to answer that question you're
having a satisfied life is a rich mix of
all those emotions at once and so I
think our motivational systems want us
to seek out a certain thing we're going
for like the positive emotion but if we
got that we wouldn't necessarily be
satisfied over time another thing we
talk a lot about is the way we frame our
different experiences and how we notice
different things so one of the reasons
that getting the kinds of things that we
want out of life doesn't make us as
happy as we forecast is we tend to get
used to stuff there's not a kind of
constant over time a kind of constant
level of positive emotion and one of the
things we talk about in class is the
fact that
as those things change over time what
our brain and our minds tend to notice
is change and so what we really want is
a host of different kinds of things
different kinds of emotions over time
and so this is sort of the type of thing
we talk about is that it might be that
one of the things we're really
interested wanting is a particular
notion of a kind of positive emotion
that's like constant and perfectly
positive over time but what would really
actually make us feel like we're
flourishing and fulfilled is exactly
what you're suggesting is different
kinds of emotions over time and in
different ratios now the social
scientist in me wants to ask the
question of like okay what's the magic
bullet you know do I need like 8%
nostalgia and do I need like a nostalgia
all the time and do those things to my
knowledge those studies haven't been
done but this is the kind of thing that
I think positive psychologists want to
look at is like is there a magic
combination what is it
you know how much negative stuff do you
need to balance and notice the positive
things happening those are the kinds of
questions that folks are I think really
interested in
so I understand a wonderful motivation
I'm thinking of the backend of data
analysis and and you have so many
students but on the other hand you know
there's been this issue going back to
the 70s we know of and more recently
with Joe Henrik and other people about
that we're people and that that college
undergrads are don't necessarily
generalize to everybody else so I wonder
if the Coursera course has which is so
they're so good at collecting data
whether that I know it's early but
whether maybe that looks like they're
going to be able to provide
cross-cultural data yeah it's a great
question so this in teaching this course
one is humbled by in some cases how bad
the data on this stuff really are and
one of the spots I think the data in the
social science just is incomplete is in
the sense of having like a good
cross-cultural samples for studying this
stuff like most of the positive
psychology work is in general done with
Western populations often college-age
populations like you want a richer
sample and you tend not to have that in
exactly the data that you have you know
there might be the hope to do that on
Coursera right now we have about 25,000
people enrolled in the short version of
the Coursera class we're not explicitly
taking lots and lots of different kinds
of data but we're doing a few kinds of
analyses about whether or not people who
do these practices more are doing
changes in their happiness over time and
again happiness here is defined as those
two sort of measures I mentioned before
sort of people's reported life
satisfaction and if people kind of
choose to opt in some of their changes
in these positive emotions over time but
yeah I think that finding a way to get
better across cultural samples is going
to be really important there's going to
be enormous differences in the kinds of
practices that work and that don't work
and it would be fantastic to have those
data I think we don't have those now but
it would be really important to get
whatever methods we can to look at that
more deeply one one final quick question
like I can't help but feel a little
frightened by the scale of some of the
results for getting in a certain way
so when this class first was I saw in
the syllabus was was being offered I
merely thought this question is so
complicated of the good life and it's
been tackled by you know from
Aristotle's eudaimonia JEE more some
pluralism of the good various thousands
of years of people thoughts traditions
have tackled this and it's and I've
never come up with answers there's
endless ways this can be discussed and
but you mentioned in your first response
to the first question that you think if
this class was called faith in the good
life or philosophy and the good life it
would be just as popular but it seems
that the results show that people
particularly like this brand of thinking
about the good life because it's
offering in the form of reduced
scientific sort of authority in some
ways just common sense answers so sleep
is good for you yeah you know I don't
know spending free time with friends is
a good thing you know certain
statistical measurements of happiness
aren't as good as we think they are and
these are just basic things that you
would anyone should should know each ask
a little kid if what they think of
happiness and they would say these
things but and looking on your syllabus
the but the end paper the hacky Oh self
project kids have to do all of the
sounds so somewhat cold and simplistic
compared to the that you know
generations that have thought through
these details in complex book-length
long arguments about how we perceive I
mean do you at some point almost fear or
are a little bit scared of the the
consequences of this for how students
think about these complex up that it's
reductionism of some sort is now how we
can the only way that we can actually
embrace happiness or even talk about it
or think about it yeah definitely don't
fear it I think that I agree with almost
everything you said I think it is the
case that thinkers have been thinking
about this stuff for forever and these
are rich and complicated issues that
this course is not going to solve and
absolutely none of the papers I assign
on positive psychology are nearly as
well written as half of those thinkers
that you quickly mentioned through like
I'd much rather students read Aristotle
than some
you paper on a gratitude journal the
flipside is like I also see that college
students are not sleeping enough and
that if they actually just slept like
seven hours a night which they're
supposed to it might mean that like
we've actually reduced the mental health
crisis on campus and so part of me is
very utilitarian about this well I'm
like I just want students to be doing
these good practices that are gonna make
them healthier and if that comes through
the form of social science then great I
actually do really believe that if a
similar course was offered with the kind
of practical implications that my class
had and maybe a little bit of the
marketing flavor of psychology and good
life students would resonate it with as
much but my sense is like this is the
kind of thing that students were waiting
for and whatever package they got it in
they would go for it you know yes I wish
it was broader than my class I don't
know that content so it's hard for me to
teach it but yeah the flipside though is
I think there is one thing that the
social sciences can offer that I don't
see as much coming from the philosophy
side or the faith-based side and that's
the part of the course that nobody ever
talks about which is the whole second
half of the course which is on behavior
change like this is a playbook from
behavioral economics social psychology
like the ways that you think about just
creating habits and using situations to
your advantage all this stuff on nudging
your behavior like this is the kind of
stuff that like McKinsey and all these
folks are putting into place because we
need ways when you have these goals to
make yourself do this stuff and nobody
talks about that as a big part of the
class but I actually think that that's
the key like I could talk to like house
come home about the importance of
meditation and gratitude journaling but
unless you restructure your habits in
your situations it's going to be hard
for students to do it and really the
best set of research or the best kind of
way I know to put that stuff into place
is to know the empirical research about
how you can kind of hack your habits in
your situation it kind of just gets
students to do that so I agree this
might not be the best way or the nicest
way or the most eloquent way to get
students learn this I kind of just don't
care I just kind of want them to do it
but I do believe that this this approach
gives us sort of slightly unique way to
get students to do stuff and that is if
you understand how you can use your
situations to make better habits then
that's going to be powerful not just for
whatever you think how
Venus's but for whatever kinds of
behavioral goals you might have for
yourself and if you're lucky
professor Kagan will sit on the podium
I'm really delighted to be here to be
part of this event and very glad that
Yale is sponsoring these wellness
initiatives I do think that universities
at their best can be places that really
do assist us in living and seeking well
to that end I'm going to argue today
that there are three basic problems with
a pursuit of happiness and in some sense
this elaborates on some things that
Laurie Santos was touching on in the Q&A
the first is that very different things
make different people happy or make the
same person happy at different times the
second is that the meaning of happiness
is itself variable and contested and the
third is that the pursuit of happiness
is governed by an inverse logic such
that its pursuit is self-defeating
these three problems are intertwined and
so I want to say a little bit more about
each one together I think they point us
away from the pursuit of happiness and
toward the quest to live life well first
then and most briefly different things
make different people happy or make the
same person happy at different times
skiing may make you happy it terrifies
me : up by the fire with a good book
makes me happy and it may bore you
happiness as subjective well-being is
subjective some find happiness in a
fancy meal or a fast car others find
happiness tending lepers in Calcutta and
as tastes and attitudes change over time
so does what makes a person happy when I
was very young being called the little
lady made me very happy
now it would make me bristle and I'm
afraid that birthday cake with lots of
gooey icing on top
make me happy now either so that's the
first point the second point is that the
meaning of happiness is slippery ancient
Greek philosophers argued that happiness
is our final end it's that which we
pursue for its own sake and for the sake
of which we pursue everything else that
we seek but they also noted that people
mean different things by happiness some
meant pleasure self-indulgence
gratification of desires others thought
happiness was honor political power or
the philosophical life now they weren't
arguing about the meaning of the English
word happiness they were arguing about
Greek eudaimonia and we continue today
to argue about the best translation for
that Greek word is happiness the best
that we can do is human flourishing or
thriving better or life satisfaction
perhaps the English word happiness has
etymological connections with the Norse
word happy or luck as in happiness it
hasn't happened chants or perhaps this
suggests that it's a matter of luck
whether you find happiness happiness
requires good fortune happiness is
perhaps most often understood in English
as a positive feeling that you have when
something gives you pleasure or you
sense that things are going well for you
and happiness is a fairly intense form
of feeling good more intense than say
satisfaction or contentment but if
feeling good often seems to be just a
matter of luck we're also familiar with
the notion that happiness is not a
matter of luck not something that just
happens to you the Dalai Lama for
instance tells us that happiness is not
something ready-made it comes from your
own actions an inspirational speaker
Dale Carnegie says something similar
happiness doesn't depend on any external
conditions it's governed by our mental
attitude here happiness is a choice or a
mindset
not a feeling at all it is a matter of
cultivating a positive outlook of
looking for the silver lining or making
the best of things what's interesting
about happiness is that we often find
ourselves arguing over what constitutes
true happiness real happiness in a way
that we don't argue about what is true
pleasure or true elation or true
contentment arguments over true
happiness indicate that happiness is not
after all just a feeling word our
disagreements over what makes for true
happiness are not disagreements over
what will most universally are most
reliably or sustainably give rise to
this positive feeling their
disagreements over whether our energies
are meaningfully devoted to the pursuit
of this positive feeling of well-being
and that brings us to the third problem
with the pursuit of happiness that it is
self-defeating we might think that
however variable the source is a
positive effect or subjective well-being
I might at least be able to determine
what sorts of things most reliably bring
me happiness or most reliably bring lots
of people happiness and devote myself to
them and of course to some extent we do
this when it comes to the pursuit of
feeling good we surround ourselves with
the sorts of music food people we enjoy
the problem is that the pursuit of this
sort of feeling good is not ultimately
satisfying it leaves us with a meaning
deficit a big gaping hole of meaning as
we survey our endless round of activity
and wonder what it all adds up to what
it is all for and so we find our concern
shifting from the pursuit of what
psychologists have started to call
hedonic well-being subjective well-being
feeling good to what they are called a
new demonic well-being a sense of
purpose
and a higher order meaning lots of
useful studies have been done on what
sorts of things give rise to you demonic
well-being involvement in channel
and meaningful activities social
connection a sense of personal growth
and competence
I'm as fascinated with the results of
these studies as anyone else the
temptation though is to take these
studies as providing a recipe or a
roadmap to true happiness something that
will enable us to pursue eudaimonic
happiness just as we pursue hedonic
happiness if I know that people who
serve others attend worship exercise
regularly and have a dog are happier
reporting higher levels of satisfaction
with their lives and a deeper sense of
meaning and connection then I'll do
those things but here's where we run up
against the inverse logic of eudaimonic
happiness once we stop to think about it
this inverse logic is familiar to us
from popular proverb and ancient
religious teaching alike it is more
blessed to give than to receive love is
nothing till you give it away the one
who seeks her life will lose it and the
one who loses her life will find it
there's a temptation here having
recognized this inverse logic to try to
employ it in a self-serving way with
one's own happiness as end-goal but many
of these things will slip through your
grasp if they're pursued for
instrumental reasons as means to the end
of one's own happiness take friendship
friendship cultivated just for the sake
of improving one's own well-being is it
really friendship
similarly committing yourself to a
higher purpose in life just for the sake
of securing your own personal well-being
is not really committing yourself to
that higher purpose committing yourself
to a higher purpose means being willing
to devote time and energy to it that
could be spent in other ways being
willing to sacrifice for it if you're
not willing to sacrifice then we would
question your commitment to the cause
say that in your search for happiness
you become involved in advocating for
undocumented persons but then you read
that people who are involved in
environmental activism report especially
high levels of eudaimonic well-being do
you switch
committments if so what kind of
commitment did you have to begin with a
read sort of sense of meaning or purpose
can derive from a commitment that is
only a pseudo commitment so seeking to
do the sorts of things that constitute
eudaimonic happiness just in order to
find happiness is self-defeating just as
life is what happens to you while you're
busy making other plans so happiness is
what comes to you while you are engaged
in intrinsically meaningful activities
and relationships that is why you're
doing for their own sake things that are
significant and worth doing philosophers
would say that happiness supervenes that
comes to rest on these intrinsically
meaningful activities Asian Greek
ethical thought as I mentioned earlier
was centered around eudaimonia as final
end but in fact the basic practical
question to which Socrates first drew
our attention is not how can I be happy
but how would I live that is waking up
to ourselves as practical agents who
assess our actions and our reasons for
action and ourselves as unified sources
of agency we ask what we are to do with
ourselves as agents what is really worth
doing and seeking and the basic answer
is that I ought to strive to live well
to make a go at this task that I find
has fallen into my lap this task of
being a practical agent of choosing
acting and living well there's a kind of
self forgetful or ecstatic character to
this pursuit the focus is not on myself
but on what is worth doing or seeking
Plato understood this in terms of the
vision of a form of the good religious
thinkers understand it in terms of the
love of God and of the love of
everything else the ones fellow human
beings at all of creation in relation to
God life is envisioned as a quest for
that which is genuinely worthy of
devotion worth spending oneself for and
I think there's immense wisdom here
wisdom that we're in danger of losing
touch
in our society today so seeking to live
well in order to find happiness is
putting the cart before the horse
rather we discover that the only kind of
happiness worth having is found in
living well this then just a bait and
switch our ordinary happiness feeling
good hedonic well-being utterly other
than living well
living a life truly worth living does
taking up the task of living well me
renouncing the pursuit of happiness yes
no this takes us back to the observation
with which I began that different things
make different people happy or make the
same person happy at different points in
their lives seeking to live life well
does mean renouncing your own happiness
your own life satisfaction as a final
end in itself as a goal worth allowing
to govern and structure your pursuits
but it does not mean a life of Stern
duty and self-denial a life of
squelching your desires and your
passions for as you take up the task of
living well seeking to engage in
pursuits that are truly worthwhile your
desires are transformed you become
incapable of enjoying some of the things
that you once enjoyed and those things
and experiences can no longer make your
happy meanwhile you come to enjoy new
things you feel good when you come home
exhausted after a day spent tutoring or
working for a political campaign even
one that seems doomed and you feel bad
after binge watching Judge Judy now
maybe you might still enjoy an episode
of duty after the day of exhaustion you
become finally if all goes well capable
only of enjoying living well so we can
say now that hedonic happiness normally
supervenes on living well think of the
vegetarian who now just likes the taste
of meat or the couch potato tour and
marathon runner can't stand to go a day
without running our tastes changed as we
develop new dispositions new ways of
seeing and experiencing the world
importantly this means that examining
your present tastes what makes you feel
good now does not go very far in helping
you to
you're out how to live well since many
of your tastes are malleable and are
transformed through the process of
living not only this but your perception
of what is truly good and worthy of
devotion is also transformed in the
process of this pursuit living well
involves acquiring virtues of character
dispositions that align what feels good
with what is good for this reason
Aristotle the Stoics and the Christian
thinkers who inherited Greek thought
held that eudaimonia was impossible for
one who lacked the virtues sometimes we
are not happy because something in us is
out of joint sometimes we are not happy
because something in the world is out of
joint Living Well requires being able to
distinguish when to focus on changing
ourselves and when to focus on changing
the world the end is one that we can't
really grasp at the outset and wouldn't
recognize or see as desirable when we
set out on the journey for we ourselves
need to be transformed in order to be
able to appreciate it the best we can do
is to try to learn from those we admire
those who seem to be a step or two
further along the journey the quest for
a life worth living then is one in which
we are constantly in a process of
transforming and deepening as he is our
grasp of the end that we seek it's a
task for a lifetime
you've made a good start if you've seen
that a life devoted to the pursuit of
happiness
isn't the life worth living thanks
[Applause]
hi thank you so much for that I was
wondering in showing you contrast you
didn't Nemea with hedonic satisfaction
if you had any thoughts on modern
Seligman's 2011 modification to his
previous authentic happiness very sort
of pseudonym eeeh based approach to
positive psychology well he adds as
independently and separable pursuit
objective accomplishment as separate
from from meaning if you if you maybe
had any thoughts on whether that was
departure from what makes sense
in terms of the good life or if that's
something that is distinguishable or
wrapped into it or well what you thought
about that oh thank you yeah so Martin
Seligman is the the person who really
launched positive psychology and there
has been an important shift that he's
made essentially from hedonic happiness
to eudaimonic happiness so he's less
concerned now is promoting subjective
well-being so the sense of feeling good
those feelings and more concerned with
promoting the sense of life satisfaction
the more global sense of meaning and I
think there's a lot of really good
things going on and that the essential
point that I'm trying to make is that it
still is putting the cart before the
horse it still is saying that our end is
my end is my well-being
however defined and I'm gonna find the
means to it I'm gonna find the
instruments that lead to that and I
think it's really the other way around
that one finds what is genuinely
meaningful what is really true and good
and beautiful and you devote yourself to
those things and yes you do have the
sense of a meaningful life if you set
out in pursuit of a meaningful life your
person you're pursuing something that's
kind of kind of slipped through your
fingers
thank you it seems like meaning is for
you more outwardly oriented and
Happiness more outwardly oriented
happiness something inwardly oriented
kind of like egotistical in a certain
sense and I'm wondering to what degree
where would you anchor the outwardly
oriented Ness towards like
transformation transcendence can go in
the good way and in the bad way as we
know there Gold's greater than yourself
that give you great meaning but that are
incredibly destructive so how do you
justify the anger toward which we should
outwardly orient ourselves to is that
for you kind of like intuitive sense is
it for your faith-based sense
scientifically since how do you ground
that external thing that we should move
towards well first one worried by the
internal versus external so have a
little bit about what on what you mean
by that
so contemplation meditation you could
think that's very inward but it could be
a component a constitutive element in
the life worth living so I'm not I'm not
really doing an inward outward contrast
perhaps in quite that way but to your
question how do you actually find the
meaningful life I'm not going to give
you it I'm not going to give you a
answer on a silver platter but as I say
it that's the pursuit of a lifetime I
think part of what's very attractive to
us in in the positive psychology and
these studies is we are in a generation
where we no longer look as trustingly to
our elders and to our inherited
traditions for guidance and finding what
is true good and beautiful in finding
what is genuinely meaningful and worthy
of our devotion and science seems much
more trustworthy to us and so we look in
that direction I think they're wonderful
things that we can learn one of the one
of the interesting thing that that has
happened as psychologists have have
become aware of how important say it is
to have had role models that we look up
to you for the wisdom in finding the
meaningful life
that they've incorporated that into
their studies so we have studies of
exemplars and how do you how do you
figure out well who are the real
exemplars well in these studies your
nominee you'd get a whole bunch of
people to nominate so you take a lot of
people that are probably not very wise
or virtuous and you just ask them who do
you think is better than you right and
we're gonna then take those people and
we're gonna we're gonna ask them what
they think is meaningful and important
in life so in the sense you could say
that really is just doing what we've
been doing all along in terms of trying
to I people bit further along the way
than we are but it's trying to use some
of the tools of empirical research to
expand our pool of wisdom thank you so
in talking about a meaningful life and
meaningful work I'm wondering if maybe
you could talk a little bit more about
burnout something I've noticed in myself
and a lot of my friends who do work
around environmental issues and and
really any social issue is that there's
intense joy and meaning in the work that
we do but at the same time especially if
you're young
you get to a point where you're well
your your physical well-being and then
your spiritual well-being suffers
because it feels overwhelming people
tend to throw out their any kind of
personal self-care out the window and so
it there's there is this balance I think
between having a very meaningful life
and also the the flip side of that where
we're burnout is common and I'm
wondering what you think about that
absolutely and I can say that's not just
this doesn't just hold when you're young
absolutely it's critical if you are
committed to something like that to take
care of yourself so that you can sustain
that commitment so the life we're living
doesn't mean oh I'm not going to neglect
myself and I'm going to I'm going to
only do this one activity all of these
techniques for sustaining your energies
become important but they become
important
a slightly different way right it's not
it's not oh my aunt my aim is to feel
good or even my aim is my life being
worthwhile your aim is this worth
worthwhile saying that is that is
calling you that maybe needs to be made
right right you know that you can't die
with a good conscience of you haven't
devoted yourself in some way to trying
to to do your best to combat it well but
you're not gonna do a good job of that
if you burn out and so you actually do
need to maybe meditate and get a dog and
do all of these other things in order to
be able to sustain that's pursuit so I
don't see it as at all as an either-or
now thank you so I was just wondering
what whether self-deception would create
any problems for your account or not so
much so I was just think of an example
say in say Finland teaching is a
prestigious and well-paid profession and
perhaps coincidentally that's punished
passion for many people and I'm from New
Zealand where teaching is not such a
well paid or prestigious profession and
they can't get enough teachers so
they're perhaps quiz coincidentally it's
not so many people's passion so could it
be that in some sense there could be
some self-deception about the true aims
of say becoming a teacher absolutely so
I I certainly want to underscore that
this pursuit is a pursuit of a lifetime
in part because we need to be changed in
part because the world needs to be
changed and apart because we may not
know what needs to be changed right and
so we are we are engaged in something
that calls on all of our all of our
energies to be aware of the possibility
that not only we ourselves but our whole
environment has worked in ways that is
concealing what's genuinely worthwhile
do I have a perfect fix to that no I
think I am absolutely fascinated with
the ways in which we're learning about
some cognitive biases that are you know
apparently universally human can
certainly benefit from knowing that sort
of thing as well as from studying
history as well studying literature to
gain more insight into our shared faults
and foibles
[Applause]
table or podium I had no my a no idea my
colleagues had such serious views about
where I should sit and stand and I think
that'll hold me so I'll follow uh Laurie
here and sit down actually before I get
started or maybe this is getting started
there's at least one thing that Laurie
said that was completely false which is
that had anybody else taught a class
like with this sort of subject matter
would have gotten comparable enrollments
I did and I didn't
[Music]
now part of the explanation of that and
I think she suggested as well which is
that there's a practical aspect of her
classes I don't understand it but
certainly when I teach at least topics
in the same neighborhood
believe me isn't there and the same
thing is going to be true in terms of
what I'm saying things going to be oh
that case let's turn the lights off yeah
same things going to be true in terms of
what I say today I mean although I hope
to raise some questions that from a
slightly different angle than the first
two people who spoke not at all clear
what the practical takeaway value of
this is but it's just trying to get
clear about what's genuinely valuable so
the title for today's session is
happiness and or the good life and I
suppose the the main thing I want to
suggest is happiness isn't really all
it's cracked up to be
it's not that it's unimportant far from
that but it's but it's much less
important than then one might think III
imagine that effect Laurie said the same
thing that that many of the much of the
reasons that so many students are
flocking to her class is because many
many Yale students are unhappy in a lot
of ways and that and that's bad and that
gets in the way of doing what's and
attain me what's genuinely valuable but
it's easy to slip in to the thought that
so happiness is what's genuinely
valuable now Jennifer also spoke to this
issue in suggesting that
well we have to you know you can't aim
at happiness
I don't recall whether you use the
phrase the paradox of happiness that's
that's the term that philosophers use
when they want to think about this
subject that if you know if my goal in
life is to make myself happy it will
just turn out to be the case that I
won't be as happy as I would be there's
something mildly paradoxical about that
but I can make myself happier by wanting
other things for their own sake and then
if I get those things or if I'm at least
pursuing those in a diligent way that I
get happiness as well so you'll you'll
get more happiness by not aiming at it
that may be slightly paradoxical but it
but it seems to be true still there's a
lot of suggestion especially in lorries
you think about you know what's lowest
class do and it's teaching you
techniques to get the right kinds of
feeling tones the right feelings and
then again Jennifer distinguishes
between the how am I feeling right now
I think that was hedonic well-being and
then there's you know what kind of
feelings of overall satisfaction with
the meaningfulness of my life I think
that was supposed to be you diamonique
well-being but it's all feelings right
it's it's all having certain thoughts or
being in the right kinds of mental
states those are important but they're
they're not I think the bottom line now
again it may be that that was part of
what Jennifer was suggesting because
you're saying really who ought to be
aiming at the meaningful life and so
maybe my resistance to her Jennifer was
saying it was I liked the conclusion but
not the argument because insofar is the
argument for that is pointing to the
paradox of hedonism you could imagine
another thought that if you aim that
happiness you won't achieve it so in
order to achieve happiness you have to
aim at something else and furthermore
you can't just aim at those other things
as a way of getting happiness because
then you won't have the right attitudes
and commitment or other things you won't
really
become happy hence the name the paradox
of happiness still somebody who is a
hedonist who does think it's all about
having the right kind of feeling tones
could completely agree with that and say
so I will bring up my children let's say
so as to care about other things because
I know that that's the only way for them
to get the happiness which is what's
really valuable for its own sake right
it's a pity that we can't keep that
thought in mind that's this bizarre fact
about human psychology but that's still
the ultimate truth about what's valuable
it's getting these positive feelings
whether about my life right now about my
life as a whole about the meaningfulness
of my life you know the deepest most
rewarding most desirable feelings are
these mental states in which I think my
life has been a meaningful one what have
you so I don't think that argument
actually undercuts the thought that
happiness is really what it's all about
unfortunately if we keep that Maat
thought at the forefront of our mind
that I'll get in the way of our
achieving what it's really all about but
still it's true for all that that that's
what it's really all about so I'm gonna
say no no that's not really what it's
all about at all and so again I think
this may be agreement with Jennifer and
at least in certain moods it may be an
agreement with Lori as well but so may
just offer a different kind of argument
for the same conclusion there's a
science-fiction version of this argument
I often give the science-fiction version
for those of you who are aficionados
this is the experience machine maybe
I'll say something about that later but
in somebody give you at least a mildly
more realistic version though still
still fanciful so often when I talk
about this example I talked about
deceived businessmen were here an Esso
and so maybe that would be appropriate
but yeah since we not all I presume you
know
at the business school let's just talk
about the deceived academic so so
imagine somebody who has really
accomplished something in terms of their
research that is to say they've you know
I don't know what it might be that
they've discovered certain overlooked
paintings by some painter or maybe the
painters Diaries what-have-you and the
basis of this have really revolutionized
our interpretation of this person's work
and its value and its contribution to
the history and development of art
they're completely you know they've got
a family so they're they're respected
you know in the in their feel our
history they've got a family that loves
them you know an adoring spouse husband
wife whatever you fill in the blank you
know their kids really you know admire
love and respect them and they die happy
and and and and they can have you know
and an early enough age internalize the
worries about the paradox of hedonism
right so they committed themselves you
know to these various things and they
and they die happy no that's the story
that I told you but here's what was
really going on unbeknownst to them the
paintings on the basis of which they
offered this new interpretation of the
painter were forgeries this comes out
after the death of the person the diary
about you know who they were inspired by
that was also forged their spouse
doesn't really love them their spouse
was sleeping with you know their
graduate students the the kids you know
don't really like like the parent but
you know they want to get the keys to
the car and so they pretend to like them
other people in the profession really
despise this person but they're so
influential that they suck up to them
right now if we ask the question did
this person die happy I actually think
English pulls us in both directions
about this there's a part of us wants to
say well a person wasn't really fully
happy but I think the dominant answer
here is yes of course the person died
happy certainly in terms of their
feelings of hedonic positive tones we
can imagine that you know their life was
filled with us dominating the negative
feeling tones if we ask about the sense
of accomplishment that they had they
have a sense of accomplishment they have
a sense they've done something
meaningful so it seems to me that the
dominant response here is that they die
happy but if the question is didn't they
have the kind of life that you want to
have for yourself
well actually the second I'm going to
ask for show of hands
you know on that one but you know you
might wonder is that the kind of ideal
now of course I don't care at all about
art history so that wouldn't be the life
that I hoped no our historians are
bother my I'm not saying that yeah but
filling your own rank of what the
accomplishments were that they devoted
their life to so don't get hung up on
the is this particular detail of what
we're looking for but tell some
comparable story about whatever it is
your own you know so for those people
who are in the business school here you
know you've you've you think you said up
some incredibly successful business but
in fact you know it goes bankrupt
six months after because your partner
who's the one been sleeping with you why
if you know has been also cooking the
books you know so so tell some story of
other other deception but from the
inside from the inside it's perfect its
impeccable you've got all the positive
feelings all the positive thoughts so
the question we want to ask you so is
that is that it great is that
picture of a successful human life is
that a picture of you might worry in the
second half for the vote but you know
you might worry well you know you know
what if you find out that your spouse is
cheating on you or or what if the fact
that you know the results from the
carbon dating on the painting you know
come through too soon it's a yeah you
know we can we can go that way but let's
just not let's just stipulate that the
person is they never find out and so
again the question is is that a picture
of an ideal of a good life that the kind
of life you want for yourself or the
kind of life you want for your children
okay so so show hands who thinks that is
a picture of an ideal great you know
human life okay I got a cutter at the
light so I can actually see okay who
thinks that no no that's missing
something really really important hands
up okay
alright good so so this is I've been
asking questions like this of my
students here my whole career and this
is pretty typical for those of you who
didn't look around I guess something
like twenty percent of you said yeah
sign me up this is great but those two
as much as 25 percent of you but the
majority of you the vast majority of you
maybe 75 maybe 80 percent thought yeah
this really isn't everything now of
course it's not that it's worthless
this person is I presume happiness
they're they're happy they've got
happiness but what I think we've
discovered by thinking about cases like
that is well we don't happiness isn't
all it's cracked up to it's not really
the bottom line this person wanted
accomplishment they thought they had
accomplishment but they hadn't really
accomplished anything significant this
person wanted love and respect they
thought they had love and respect but in
fact they didn't this person wanted
knowledge about their field but and
about their own success with regard to
that field but they didn't really have
knowledge what we learned from I think
thought experiments like this is that
what's genuinely bottom line most
valuable isn't happiness it's these
other things and you know so Jennifer
was suggesting this sometimes you know
gaining these other things will bring
happiness in its wake and that's true it
might but then again you know it might
not and it might be that sometimes it's
worth sacrificing your happiness to go
after the things that are genuinely
worth having alright at this point thank
you yeah so Joshua asks you know so I
didn't save anybody fix and in fact very
little about ethics appeared I mean the
phrase the good life I think is somewhat
ambiguous sometimes when we talk that
way or a life worth living we mean
taking into account everything that one
needs to take into account how should
you live your life and given the fact
that you know I'm not the only person in
the world you're not the only person in
the world there are moral demands on us
and a certainly if we mean the super
broad inclusive notion of what's worth
doing with one's life then I absolutely
of course think that being moral is an
important part of that I mean I
specialize in moral philosophy
most of what I teach is on different
aspects of what is morality require of
us on the other hand notice the
following thing what most of us agree
maybe not everybody or most of us agree
is that in certain circumstances
morality will demand that you make a
sacrifice of some sort for others and
yet we could argue about what kind of
sacrifice is what limits might there be
to that but notice that when you do that
in order to make sense of that
description we have to have the thought
that although you are living the more
like you and you know yourself giving up
but what's a value to you yourself the
benefit you are sacrificing some of your
well
being for the sake perhaps of of
promoting the well-being of others and
maybe that's that's the right thing to
do maybe morality really does demand
that but it to make sense of that claim
we have to have a notion of what were
you giving up that was genuinely
valuable and that's the notion of the
good life that at least for today's
discussion I think we've been focusing
on that is you know what is what are the
ingredients of a life that is valuable
for that person whose life it is their
even having said that that's a bit too
crude because one might then fold that
back in and say if you yourself are not
living a moral life than one of the
ingredients of the genuinely worth
wildlife for your own sake is missing
you know if I've listed achievement and
I listed knowledge and I listed love and
friendship and then and meaningful
relations but I would make the claim as
well that being a virtuous individual is
itself good for you such that your life
is going less well in terms of what you
got out of it if you're not virtuous but
that's a that's a longer argument for
another day is there a difference
between socially recognized
accomplishment and just the
accomplishment felt by one itself I feel
like in the and the thought experiment
that you laid out the the reason that it
was still a virtue well lived life is
because the person who died died feeling
like they had accomplished something
even though socially recognized their
work was meaningless and their family
didn't actually love them I is does
there need to be some aspect of like
social recognition so when you said you
know the reason you thought within the
story about the deceived you know
academic why their life was well if that
take it you mean the reason you voted
that way is that the way yes so because
I'd course I wouldn't vote that way I
would vote that their life was not well
lived that their life had been in many
of
most important aspects of failure now
that's not to say that their life was a
hundred percent of failure they I don't
think happiness is not worth anything
you were to make a list of all the
things worth wanting out of life we're
not giving you accomplishment and I've
given you knowledge and I've given you
meaningful relationships and I've and I
threw in a virtue in response to
Joshua's question and now I'd I would
want to throw in as well you know
happiness in these feeling tone sensors
that we've been talking about you know
or pleasure broadly construed that's a
constituent as well but let's go back to
the one you were particularly focused on
on achievement so what I guess if we had
more time and in the class I said I was
mentioned in the introduction that I
teach a class and death you know there
this other classes class called life you
know so for many many years I knew I
wanted to teach a class called life I
didn't know why I would put in it by
just how could I resist so you know so
one of the one of the weeks in that
class we talked about the nature of
accomplishment and what makes an
accomplishment genuinely worth having a
valuable accomplishment as opposed to
you know you accomplished something in
some sense of the word and so you're
suggesting that you know maybe we should
you know your own sense of
accomplishment may be relevant or at
least your having done something that
you value but I and and it's not
certainly not just a question of what a
society think I mean when I told the
story it wasn't supposed to be that
society falsely came to believe the
paintings were forgeries and so they no
longer thought that person had
accomplished it he told the story that
way I would think maybe the person
really did accomplish something it just
hasn't been recognized the good that I
would want to list would be genuine
accomplishment and that would involve
it's interesting philosophical question
what is it to actually have a genuine
accomplishment I don't quite think it's
a matter of do you believe you did it
NORs I think it a matter of do you can
do others believe you
nor is it a matter of did you at least
get what you wanted whether or not you
realize you got what you wanted I think
we need to fit filling that what you
were aiming for genuinely was worth
aiming for and so I would myself move
away from thinking too heavily about
individuals takes on whether you've
accomplished anything - whether you've
actually accomplished anything I don't
control the mic so I don't know who's
got yeah could you speak a little bit
more about the time discrepancy problem
in that thought experiment you just went
over it seems to be that the person at
least believes that they had genuine
accomplishment when they were dead sorry
when they were alive and then following
that when they're dead none of these
things really matter anymore because
they're dead so that can't affect them
when it's revealed that nothing was
actually good so one point is of course
it's not crucial to the story as I told
them in the way I did telling the story
where it turned out after they're dead
that these were forgeries but you know
it could be that the forgeries were
known to be forgeries by the forger if
they were contemporary forgeries during
the person's life so the issues not
really I think a matter of time you know
though that brings out a certain
implication of the kind of account of
well-being that I'm drawn to which is
that well-beings not really primarily a
function of whether you realize you're
well-off or not I mean in in in in in
the ideal circumstances you not only
have accomplishment and loving relations
and knowledge and virtue but you realize
it and then Allah Jennifer's early and
no doubt Lori's earlier thoughts you
know that would in fact increase your
pleasure you take pleasure in the
realization that you have these things
but of course it could also be the case
that youth and that was the point of the
deceived business person or the deceived
academic that you thought you had these
things and in fact you don't the crucial
point is not whether the you know the
evidence for your
kingdom comes out later or early or
never comes out at all the crucial
question and the crucial point is did
you really have these valuable things or
did you merely labor under the illusion
that you had these things what this
means is well-being is not something
about which we are infallible detectors
in terms of our own well-being you may
think you are really really well off and
you just might might not be and that's
precisely where I think you know it's
really visible the wedge between welfare
on the one hand and happiness on the
other it's much harder to tell a story
where you think you are feeling content
with your life that you're not really
feeling you know we've got to go
Freudian now you know start
distinguishing what your conscious
thoughts versus your unconscious
thoughts oh you know I'm not saying such
stories can't be told but to be really
simple minded about it can you be
feeling pleasure and not realizing
you're feeling pleasure that's a harder
story to tell but I think that just goes
to show there's a lot more to well-being
than happiness you really can be
mistaken about whether your life is
going well or not and indeed emails will
strike some people as bizarre or
paradoxical or just show why this kind
of view is unacceptable it could turn
out that you know how well your life
read how well off you were while you're
alive isn't settled until things after
your life come to pass the success of
your life partly depends on what happens
after your life and so to the extent
that success is a crucial ingredient in
success of the right sort to in having
the best kind of life your level of
welfare can be hostage to what happens
after your death you've had your hand up
a couple of times but the people if the
microphones never see you so now I
brought the huge filter tensioning this
the final question okay thank you when
you brought up did you really have
happiness or a meaningful life or were
you under a leap where you did you labor
under the illusion that you did my
question is exactly to that point about
deception and about delusion so I want
to ask you about the role of delusion in
a good life because in your scenario
delusion is bad and I think there's the
assumption that once you become aware of
your own delusion that you'll abandon it
but I don't think this is necessarily so
and I think this also gets to what
you're talking about is the genuine so
who here is the arbiter of the genuine
and can't you also occupy your own
delusion in a genuine way Wow
okay so obvious I'll do complete justice
to that about a minute and a half right
so so you know if the question is could
certain delusions be useful sure I take
it this is just a sort of thing that the
psychologists who I don't read you know
you know tell us about right so I mean
I'm the causal question could certain
false beliefs be useful yes well I was
suggesting you was that yeah I my list
of things was knowledge I haven't hadn't
spoken much about that but I think now
is in a particular self-knowledge is one
of the intrinsic goods of the best kind
of life and if you are deluded like my
deluded academic that lack of knowledge
about their place in their community
their success thing whether that in and
of itself means the quality of their
life their level of well-being has is
lowered by virtue of that very fact it's
not that it leans to it being lower you
know it's not because they never find
out it may not lower the level of
happiness or whatever it might be it's
that being ignorant is bad for you
in and of itself and the flipside is
knowing it is good for you in and of
itself
you know Aristotle talks about how
people desire to know this is one of the
essential goods of humankind that we can
possess knowledge of the universe and
our place in it and if you don't have
that your life to that extent is the
worse so when people say you know again
these are kind of the happiness buff and
they may be and the 20% of you
thought that the deceived academic
hadn't even had a great life that you
know what you don't know can't hurt you
right if it doesn't come back and
impinge on your mental states so you
find out about it that it can't really
be bad for you it's only bad insofar as
you find out insofar as it affects your
mental states and and the moral that I
hope at least the majority of you come
to see by thinking about the deceived
academic is that's not right what you
don't know can hurt you knowledge of our
place in the world is itself one of the
things worth striving for thank you so I
want to thank you thank all three of you
for a really wonderful set of remarks
part of why we do this is because we
want to be able to have our faculty and
and even speakers from from off-campus
come and talk to us about the various
nature of well-being and certainly
talking about happiness and or the good
life and different constructions of how
that works for us it's something that we
want to talk about today so thank you
for the wisdom that you you provided I
encourage all of you to continue
thinking about this as you go about your
about your day and certainly the rest of
the week ask those big questions and
also check out our website that yell
well website for other conversations
around this topic and others which will
hopefully support your well-being thank
you very much and have a good night
[Applause]